people really do know one state looking
the fingers will in their lives
coming up reason TV travels to Brazil
for a look at how a group of libertarian
activists help bring down a president it
definitely says great things about
Brazilian democracy
why is libertarianism catching on so
fast in the cell is how you win over
undecided voters right there
why didn't understand their ideas people
have to like our enemies if they want to
be cool they don't need to be on the
Left they can be in our group now this
is kind of my life and these young
activists help defeat the big government
populism stifling the economy of Latin
America's most populous nation this is
the worst recession we've had in
recorded history
it's like an office one of you but we
are not like seals guys so it's not
technically an office in this cavernous
production studio a group of mostly
20-somethings worked through the night
often sleeping by their desks they're
making videos uploading content to
social media and strategize we're a
group of friends and things do not work
well if the guys who are entering our
team don't become a fan of us this is
the headquarters of the free Brazil
movement it's the centerpiece of the
country's growing libertarian movement
and the group has already helped bring
about a remarkable turn of events
the free Brazil movement has been a
driving force behind the ongoing
impeachment of Brazilian President Dilma
Rousseff who in May was forced to step
down a left-wing populist
Rousseff was impeached for fiscal
impropriety it definitely says great
things about Brazilian democracy we
always had politicians just running free
and doing whatever they wanted with
public money so this is a very very big
deal but the impeachment effort probably
would have fizzled if the free Brazil
movement hadn't helped organize a
succession of demonstrations that
involved millions of anti Rousseff
protesters the anger of the Brazilian
people with their government it was cast
and explicitly libertarian terms in
Brazil all the people are libertarian in
many ways like people really do know one
state putting their fingers in their
lives when you start to explain those
things people oh yeah the government's
way too big yeah yeah this is the real
problem to keep the pressure on for
removing Rousseff from office members of
the free Brazil movement at a 33 day
march from Sao Paulo to the federal
capital Brasilia it was a 750 mile track
which they did while carrying an
impeachment bill to deliver to Congress
after arriving in Brasilia they sat down
with congressional leaders to make their
case we're going to defeat the
Socialists in Brazil the way that they
hate most by democracy Brazil is now in
the second year of recession and this is
the worst recession we've had in
recorded history the Brazilian economy
has been contracting over the last
couple years and the unemployment rate
recently climbed above 11 percent on the
2016 index of economic freedom which
categorizes countries based on the level
of government interference in the
private economy Brazil ranked a hundred
and twenty second starting a new
business in Brazil takes about 14 times
as long as it does in the United States
according to the World Bank
here's the big mystery in Brazil and in
much of Latin America how is it that so
many citizens continue to believe that
government can solve their country's
problems despite so much lived
experience to the contrary the theory
behind the libertarian movement in
Brazil is that most people derive their
politics not from reasoning or from
culture so the way to change public
policy is to create a new cultural
identity it's all about freedom if you
want to be cool you have to be for the
left if you are not from the left you
are a guy who don't like gays you don't
like poor people you don't like black
people
what is the brazil movement britta
movement is other way young guy or a
young real go they don't need to be on
the left group now they they can be in
our group to promote this new
libertarian cultural identity a free
Brazil movement functions in part as an
alternative media outlet with its more
than 1.3 million Facebook followers the
median Brazil receives lots of money
from the government and we had to create
a sort of parallel media terms of
Facebook we're stronger than any
politician in Brazil and we have more
views more rich than any group
as a video production shop the free
Brazil movement scored one of its
biggest hits in 2014 with the joke
advertisement for Paulo Bautista a
longshot candidate for the South Paulo
state legislature this is a politician
flying over fat eye and spreading the
libertarian message using a beam that
comes from his eyes that turns bad
public all services need to use private
services it drew a front page story in
The New York Times and was featured on
the John Oliver's show perhaps my
favorite candidate this year is this guy
Paulo Bautista who seems to be running
on a platform of having laser vision
that can transform the country and who
ends the ads by flying through space for
20 solid seconds we have not edited this
this is genuinely how his campaign ad
ends and that is how you win over
undecided voters right there
the video was aimed not at promoting
Batista's candidacy but at rebranding
the concept of privatization privatizing
that was a word that I left made as a
stir in terms of product points it
became something that people it's nice
because people were starting to use as a
meme like oh I had a girlfriend who's
not looking pretty nice in his picture
so she she received the privatizing
being and she becomes hot we have a
footage from our demonstrations where
like thousands of people are screaming
in the middle of avenues we should
privatize those public are but is now
critics of the free Brazil movement say
that its message has mostly caught on
with the middle class in South Paulo in
the South making less traction in
Brazil's far poorer
northern states Brazil is a very very
poor country so to be fiscally
conservative you have to convince and
this is the hard part you have to
convince people that being fiscally
conservative means in the medium to
longer term have you more money to spend
in education and health enter 20 year
old Kim category the grandson of
Japanese immigrants a part-time law
student in Sao Paulo and the free Brazil
movements biggest star one of his
specialties is communicating how free
market reforms benefit the poor just
observe what the left has already done
they've created the perfect formula more
than understand their ideas people have
to like our ideas so I think that's the
great secret we have like 205 million
people in Brazil I mean you will never
make 305 million people understand any
idea in a profound way education for an
example we don't explain that the
voucher system is more efficient and it
has working in other countries and the
private companies can take a better care
of the schools we just asked so do you
want the poor people which are studying
the same school the rich people I mean
it looks real it really looks like a
leftist speech but we're defending what
this is
selling to the people ideals of not only
liberty but also of equality and showing
that equality it's not only a value of
the leftist but we also can do it on a
Thursday evening a group of college
students meet up at a bar in a
residential neighborhood of Sao Paulo
they're members of students for liberty
an international organization that
brings together libertarians on campus
it has a presence in a hundred and seven
countries including the US but based on
the count of local coordinators who've
signed up with the group
the Brazilian chapter is bigger than
students for liberty in every other
country combined everybody can see that
government is not working for us as it
should I was thinking if there is any
option and I discovered that that is and
now this is kind of my life Mozilla is
better at reverse reface 2gb rise up in
square a maestro salvadora yoni cenizas
hi cheek when you see water blocky in
meetings takeaway there was your day my
Kundalini the reason students for
Liberty has seen exponential growth in
Brazil in contrast to other countries is
something of a mystery mariana lyon
points to the collapse of socialism in
the region particularly in Venezuela so
I think that this is a secret it's when
everybody starts to realize that we can
go from here to somewhere worse it may
also be that the Brazilian branch of
students for liberty has particularly
good organizational tactics coordinator
Roni Stephan Otto rodriguez recruits new
members by spending about two hours a
day listening in as strangers discuss
the latest news on Facebook when he
finds someone making libertarian
sounding arguments he reaches out it's
like a headhunter they are the way to be
alive retires and I always say hey I
have this book Joanna Ridge
the libertarian movement in Brazil would
never have gotten off the ground if it
weren't for a handful of think tanks
that started laying the groundwork many
years ago one major player is Mises
Brazil which occupies a shared office in
this building in downtown Sao Paulo and
as unaffiliated with the us-based think
tank with the same name the chief of
operations is 24 year-old Gianluca Loren
zone the question that I asked myself
was why we talk about Friedan our songs
and our lyrics in our poetry all the
time but simply this doesn't reflect on
politics and the reason is because we
didn't have content Mises Brasil
publishes daily articles on libertarian
issues and gets him about a million
pageviews per month it's also both
commissioned and brought back into print
Portuguese translations of the major
works of Austrian economics Mises Brazil
was founded in 2007 by investment banker
alia Bhatt Rao he says the intellectual
climate in Brazil has undergone a
profound shift they would look at me
like Lu has read something that made him
crazy and I think that changed over the
last 10 years or maybe less and now they
only think I'm radical
now that libertarian activists have
helped push Dilma Rousseff out of office
where does that leave the country
Rousseff was replaced by her vice
president Michel temer a former
congressman who's been in politics for
nearly 30 years
Tamir has been implicated in brazil's
ongoing corruption scandals on a scale
of 1 to 10 10 being the most corrupt I
would say he's a 6 the libertarians have
little faith in Tamara the person they
say the impeachment has created
political incentives that are leading
him to make some positive changes
whatever is betting his government on is
to bring about much-needed economic
reforms to get unemployment down and
he's counting on this to happen in like
six or eight months so he can stay in
office the politicians have interest and
maximize their time in office and if we
turn the libertarian ideas politically
profitable then in either way we're
gonna win and I think it's good not to
have this populist figure of the person
view brothers freedom who will brought
freedom to the people is the ideas
themselves the impeachment is just the
start of the game and we should put the
pressure over him kick all those who
applies who are there and they are still
there and pressure him to make the the
good economical and the good democratic
reforms that we need to change our
political system I don't see any way of
changing policy besides getting involved
in politics there's also a movement
afoot to elect actual libertarians to
political office 31 year old economist
Fabio Osterman has been an important
behind-the-scenes figure in libertarian
circles and now he's running for mayor
of huerto Alegre a southern city with a
population of about 1.5 million
I think Brazilian libertarians are
getting ready to take this next step
Ostrom and has led a takeover Brazil's
social Liberal Party which is planning
to put forward many more libertarian
political candidates in the near future
or a party that the defense both gay
marriage decriminalization of marijuana
and also of course free markets free
trade deregulation of the economy
privatizations and we know that we
we'll be displeasing a lot of people by
defending these ideas but we feel like
it's the right thing to do we're not yet
a libertarian country we're actually
very far from that unfortunately but
this is a very special moment for
libertarians in Brazil because we're
showing up as an option as an
alternative